this podcast and every other podcast on
my channel is brought to you by my
subscribers on patreon these wonderful
people are the reason that i'm able to
make so many shows that feature all
different kinds of people who work in
the games industry from writers to
developers to creative directors as well
as a new show that'll be launching in a
couple of weeks featuring voice actors
outside of just the important support
that helps me make this content patreon
supporters also get things early
unedited and completely ad-free they
also get to ask questions for podcasts
and have input on merch and in-person
events as well so if you would like to
support video game writing 101 or any of
my other shows please consider
subscribing on patreon it will help me
make better cooler stuff with more
people hello everyone i'm alana and
welcome to another episode of video game
writing 101 i have two very exciting
guests joining me today would you like
to introduce yourself lucas you want to
go first oh sure uh yeah my name is
lucas loreto and uh i was one of the
narrative designers for weird west i was
in charge of the main storyline
uh raph how about you
uh well i'm rafael con antonio i'm the
founder of arcane studios back in the
day uh so that was in 99 and uh since
then i left in 2017 and uh eventually
about two years later we
[Music]
made the company called warfi studios
and i'm the creative director for wild
west
so for anyone who doesn't know the game
did just come out to catch people up uh
what exactly is it
well so you know i had to uh i changed
my mind now that i've seen so many
tweets and so many uh people talking
about it because initially i was
presenting it as an action rpg immersive
sim and i think
the gamers define it a little better
than that they say it's a crpg that
plays like an arpg
and uh that's very specific so many
acronyms
that was pretty cool uh
you know it's kind of easier to listen
to what gamers think of the gamer
because it's always hard to our games
are always extremely hard to market
because they have this this hybrid
quality which is
kind of a mind [ __ ] for marketers
usually uh but uh yeah i mean yeah i do
think there's uh immersive sims
qualities which also is like a mouthful
and doesn't mean much to most people
but you know i think uh yeah somewhere
there
lucas how would you describe it
uh
i'm not up on all the acronyms as well
as twitter is uh
i would say that raf's description is
totally right i mean for the folks who
hear immersive sim and that means
something that's really what our game
does um
and i would say yeah action rpg
for me it's all about the fact that it's
set in the wild west and we got pigmen
and we got werewolves we got things that
go bump in the night we got scary stuff
we got beautiful stuff we got funny
stuff
um i think we
at least we worked hard to make sure
there was a good story in there as much
as we could do it i think you did a
pretty good job of that
um the thing that stands out to me
like if i'm to remove the acronyms for
yeah people watching maybe i'll put some
footage over this is that it is like a
dark fantasy take on the west which is
very very interesting so how did that
come about as a setting
um
i think a few of us wanted to do the the
west
uh specifically uh
we have a lead animator etienne ober
who's a big fan of westerns
and uh
i like them too but personally i like
when there's a little more fantasy to it
and uh so that's how it organically
became
uh reimagining like a dog fantasy
version of uh
of the west you know i think they i mean
fantasy is great for many reasons you
can you can come up with interesting
stories but also they provide a lot of
gameplay elements and powers and stuff
that is just fun for games it makes it
sound so simple i imagine it was a
little bit hotter than that
who's torturous wasn't it was it total
torture
well it was very iterative for sure yeah
at first i remember we were like okay
this is gonna be 95 western
and five percent weird five percent
uh fantasy and then
it was not enough fantasy you know so
you kind of like move the slider until
it feels right i think now i would say
we're like 70 30 or something like that
that feels about right yeah yeah
and some of the journeys are way more
the slider is a little bit further i
mean when you're playing the pigman
journey that thing's just 100 weird the
whole time
i love it
i'm a big fan of the weird uh but when
you're going you know to to make
the
debut game from this new studio that
you've made that people are very excited
about because you have a lot of talent
from arcane
uh
like where do you start like what's the
approach for like if this is the thing
that defines the start of this new
studio like how do you that just seems
like a lot of pressure is sort of my
question how did you decide on weird
west
uh
i think it it was very easy because um
my co-founder julian roby was
with me at arcane since
2000 frankly so he's seen all the games
he's been part of them and you're still
not sick of each other that's amazing
they love each other you guys love each
other
we love jillian we we both have like an
implicit understanding for the kind of
games we like and uh the frankly the
if you think of ark's fatalities the
first game we made
uh or the last game i made which was
prey uh he was not with me at that time
he had left arcane already but he had
been with me for
easily 15 years you know and so i did
pray without him but where we but it's
all those games they really share the
same dna the same uh that mix of
uh simulation and storytelling which is
so hard because the the systems
really
the game shines at the intersection
between the the the the authored
storytelling and the systems and the
story that the player tell themselves
and uh those are always very very hard
to make and uh they
cause a lot of bugs and uh they
they require the the players to uh
to somehow
co-create their own adventure you know
how do you feel about that lucas in
terms of like narrative design would you
would you agree with that being a
complicated component
oh it's it's so hard i mean i sort of
don't really have anything i don't have
much to compare it to because
i had worked on
a couple smaller projects before coming
on uh at wolfi
but nothing like this and to say okay
this is the first time you're going to
be in charge of the main storyline of a
game by the way every character can be
killed any time you want
and the story has to keep going and it
has to be interesting um
that's hard
it's really hard well that's the thing
i'd love to dig into and it's one of my
favorite questions to ask people who
come on the show is like what is one of
the most unexpectedly difficult things
about your job so like a lot of
developers listen to the show but
they're also people who know nothing who
don't even know what narrative design
means as a job right
like
what
how do you approach
something like that like an evolving
narrative where the player is so much a
part of the uh story process like what
literally how does that happen
yeah good program
i mean i'm really lucky that i came into
a studio where you know as raf was
mentioning the people who are working on
this game have you know 20 years of
experience working on immersive sims
already and have seen a lot of these
things before i was coming in very fresh
i was coming more from the
the fiction writing world and so i had a
lot to learn
um
but they had the guard rails up for me
the whole time and i made tons of
mistakes but they would sort of guide me
back and i think that
what is hardest
maybe more this might be more for the
developers listening but you know maybe
for the players too i think the hardest
thing is to figure out
literally what
game object do you put the story in is
is the story inside of an npc that you
talk to
is
for a particular story moment like say
we're we're trying to find the the gold
temple of whoever and there are uh
little nuggets along the way that lead
you there
uh is it going to be an object in the
game world that's a clue that leads you
there well in our game that's great
because you can't shoot an object dead
so you don't have to worry about it
getting destroyed from the game world
but if it's inside of an npc you're
going to talk to and have a relationship
with and they have really important
information for you and a game like ours
that's immediately a problem because the
player can choose
you know an immersive sim
when we tell you here's a gun you can
shoot it we don't say
but not don't shoot these people though
you can shoot any we give you the verb
we give you the gun you just do it
wherever you want
um
so trying to figure out where safe
places are to put story in the game is
really hard and then
deciding when you want to put the story
in unsafe places
yeah because it would be easy to talk
yourself out of it right it'd be easy to
go well but that can die so let's just
not do that but then you have no idea
because you're too scared you can't do
it it's a game of notes and diaries
which you don't want yeah
i think what you do is uh
you
you make sure that your world and you
the elements of your story are cohesive
in us in a way that is mechanically
correct so for example if
uh the door that leads to the end of the
game
or that leads to the end of that quest
is
as a key and that key
has to be on the character
that character
is could be a good character and that
character that's only that's what
matters
if if you if you play the normal way the
character will ask you to do something
you know something that might be uh even
annoying like go in the yeah find this
thing for me or whatever i've lost a
book or something
and uh
but as long as this character has the
key
you can kill a character avoid the book
thing because it's
and then like the key will still work so
as long as all the mechanics that leads
to the end of the game are in the world
in cohesive ways uh there's no you know
there's no blocking cinematic you're not
allowed to if it's a blocking cinematic
it's not a blocking cinematic to
fool the player
into you know like
those moments where you have the bad guy
coming up
and the bad guy talks and then he leaves
the room and you were like oh come on
yeah it's not satisfying it's not
allowed we don't do anything like that
so if there's a moment that someone
shows up we're not gonna
uh do this kind of trick with you so we
always gonna try to be very real about
the elements and how they connect to
each other
and then we encourage you to do the good
thing as a
because it creates an interesting
emotion a few
if you were to kill that character to
take the key it would work most players
when they start understanding your game
that's what they do they save the killer
character
character might die uh and it maybe it
was a good character maybe it was uh
someone that
talked to you before and uh
you know you kind of had some empathy
with this character and you you take the
key and now that's it you could just
proceed most people feel bad and they
would reload and do the quest instead
and i think that is something that we
had all the way back to uh to art
fatalities and
i think it's a missed opportunity in
many many games for me that that
creation of that
triggering of emotions that that like
guilt or like empathy
uh is so powerful even if most players
will play
the good way most players will do the
quest because they don't want to break
the game because they want to be bad
people but the fact that they know that
they could just kill that person gives
meaning to
the fact that they play like a good
person that's true the fact that it's an
option gives them more agency
which means they're probably more
invested in the story it's a very good
point in fact you're even giving them
the freedom means
can i just add to that that is one of my
favorite things that raph has said over
the course of this of this development
cycle that really stuck with me which is
like
when you give the player
the agency to
uh in our case in our game killing is a
main verb and that's sort of we're in
the west that's what we deal with
killing is is a big part of what happens
in our game there are guns and stuff
if you give them if you say you can do
this whenever you want you can kill your
friends whenever you want you can do all
these things in most games there's never
a threat so that you can
kill someone you care about because the
systems protect them or you shoot them
and nothing happens and the game doesn't
respond the fact that our game you can
do that means that not only are you
choosing to kill characters when you
want to
when you choose to abstain from killing
a character that's also a choice and so
there's like this feeling to me of
tension
in every moment in our game because you
know there's something you could do
that would be
really terrible but you're abstaining
from doing it and that's a choice that
most players don't get to make in a lot
of games i think it's a very powerful
thing about um video game storytelling
and this is also a question that i like
asking people is like what do you think
is the biggest strength of
video game storytelling versus other
mediums and my answer is always empathy
is that
you can you can do some very cool stuff
with empathy and games you can even take
somebody who's engaging in really poor
behavior put them in the shoes of
somebody who's engaging in poor behavior
in a game and have them realize what
their actions are doing to people like
it's very powerful tool and i feel like
sometimes we don't take advantage of it
that's a good point uh
the empathy part i think also the
the player story if you give the player
enough
tools enough uh type of verbs and a lot
of simulation
and a game that has enough breadth then
suddenly there is the there is a story
of the game but there's also the story
that the player starts to
develop
inside that story uh and that can be
okay now i gotta back i gotta go back to
the village and
get a horse because i'm i have enough of
doing this kind of thing etc like you
know i'm too slow whatever so the player
will go back to the village
um
and it doesn't have enough money or she
doesn't have enough money and now like
there's another entire new quest that
the player is gonna is gonna
and getting that money might be robbing
people because it's really hard to find
money in our game you know it's at the
beginning anyway and so at some point
it's tempting to just go to the
doctor's office and uh start to like you
know as the doctor is asleep i might
just as well like i know it's bad i'm
just gonna steal some stuff because the
game doesn't really punish me for that
and now i can finally buy the thing i
wanted and that's an entire story which
they've created that you haven't made
them
they had a whole emotional experience
and we didn't really write any of that
it's just the systems check this one
check this one i've like i've seen that
tweet uh that i thought was amazing uh
what was it exactly exactly so
the player
buried their son
and then
diggers dig him out
got the bone and the skull because in
our game there's you know the the
there's a bit of an abstraction where
once you bury someone and you dig them
up
uh dig them out then there's gonna be uh
you know they've rotten already so he
got the skull
and this he went to the store to sell
the store the skull of his song right so
it's dark right it's weird
that is not in a questline that we wrote
that's for sure
any of that we don't encourage that but
that player had that story you know that
player yeah
we did that and went like
10 out of 10. perfect because yeah those
are kind of things that
i i like
systems to really go to the uh
like elemental level the more the more
we we offer systems that might be might
be cumbersome at first like you can take
an object you can move the object you
can throw the object and drop the object
you can put in an inventory you can put
from an inventory to another inventory
that feels like windows
12 management kind of system right it
doesn't feel like a fun game
uh and then on top of that we can add
some some
uh
shortcuts to make the life easier but i
think starting with this very elemental
verbs create gameplay create story
because this is a story podcast so you
know not not going to focus on gameplay
specifically but it does create stories
yeah like the stories of the of the of
the person that sold uh their some skull
uh that is because of all those systems
that are there it's there's no other way
to do that
right so that's why i'm talking about
the the the offered story with all the
branches and all that that people
recognize and they think it's great
uh but then there's the entire system
story the player story which to me is
way more interesting frankly i think
it's also the thing that stays with
people for the longest the stories that
you create yourself yeah and they're
more unique the more like
very hard to do though a lot of a lot of
uh games don't pull it off um
right so it's a it's the mix of the the
lore that is there the the the authored
story the the personal goals that the
players might have and all those systems
everywhere that we create moments of
storytelling
lucas you mentioned uh coming from other
kinds of fiction
um what was that shift like like having
to deal with player agency and
storytelling was that a difficult hurdle
to to overcome
uh yeah it certainly was i think that um
for any writers out there who
come from a pro's background poetry
background screenwriting background i
think there is a temptation to say
well hey a lot of the games that i that
i play
have tons of great cutscenes those play
just like movies they they seem like
they're screenplays so i could probably
do that too
um i took a i was getting my mfa here at
ut austin um
in fiction but i started taking video
game writing courses from a woman named
susan o'connor who's one of the writers
for bioshock and you know she's she's
really amazing at what she does
and when i started
learning about what it takes to write
games and the sort of different
considerations that game writers have
that fiction and screenwriters don't it
becomes clear very quickly that it is
totally a different medium yes the prose
has to be good yes the dialogue has to
be good
but you're imbuing story in
every element of the game possible and
it's it's so much more of a co-creation
with the team it's working with artists
and the level designers you're talking
about story how can we
make this space
communicate story to the player and
often times
when i talk to friends about this
the
i think the closest analog
to game writing is designing and writing
immersive theater
so if you think about like
we sleep no more in new york yeah yeah
yeah totally you know exactly what i was
gonna say so sleep no more is totally
a video game that they designed right
because you
i haven't been there from but from what
i've heard
you enter the space you put on a mask
even right so you're like you're putting
on the character right
they tell you i imagine what verbs are
available to you what are you allowed to
do in this space are there any things
you can't do don't touch the performers
don't do this don't do that you can do
this you can't do that so you're given
the rules of the game and then you go
into the space and there's a story
happening all around you but it's not
linear there are branches everywhere the
performers are also improvising based on
the input that the participants are
giving right and then there are these
little authored moments sprinkled
throughout where you get these you know
one-on-ones with actors so
um
it's been fun thinking of it in that
context and i think
definitely the biggest
learning for me has been to try to
uh let go of leading the player by the
nose quite so much raph knows that i
have this problem or at least
hopefully it's something i've learned
from after doing the um doing weird west
but i just want to lead the player by
the nose i want there to be some great
dialogue some great scenes let me take
you through a great story but it's
really not the way to do narrative
design for a game and especially not for
an immersive sim
yeah especially not for immersive sim
but i think uh you you nailed it with
the theater example and i think i was
going to say uh even like it's more of a
dungeon master kind of
size right like if you like this in
other type of games right you you work
you you work on us on on a space and
then on a space of possibilities and you
have to think of all the things that you
can control
and then the the fallbacks for the thing
you don't control
of course when you play a pen and paper
uh
pen and paper rpg you have you have more
chance to improvise which you can't in
the video game but uh but that's why the
systems are here and you hope that they
somehow fall back on the feet when
things go wrong uh so that for example
if you attack an entire city then you
still have to think of okay now what do
we do like in in the case of the player
being enemies of all the people
including the quest givers that's why
you want to make sure that the keys on
the is on the people yeah
so it's not it doesn't rely on them
talking to you right
uh but we we you know back in the day
when we uh hired uh lucas we we uh
we chose lucas because he's um
it's super smart and we we uh
i mean anyway i was interviewing him for
that role and i knew that he would be
able to have one of the
uh skills to me that is extremely
important for a
game writer or a narrative designer
is an understanding is a transversal
understanding of the entire world
and making those connections because
it's a it's a job that is you're kind of
the keeper of of the lore and the and
the story of of this game and it's
extremely iterative it changes every
minute
uh as we see players playing we need
which we think of a different thing as
we
uh want to insert a new story or
something doesn't work we gotta break
things and as you move something here
there's gonna be 65 different different
consequences over there there there and
there
and it takes that kind of brain that
kind of like
uh
global understanding of every
consequence to what you do as a from a
from a game standpoint not from not from
a game at some point to be able to
maintain that thing so it's a very
exhausting
mental exercise where uh even i when i
if i'm part of of uh you know modifying
the main plot or something it's easy for
me to come in and say like you know i
don't like that plot twist it's kind of
like how about we do this instead about
like i got this new idea and uh
and you know so some of them were were
actually better than what we had so
uh and he was like great but i don't
have to worry about what it means he
does yeah he was like hold on hold on
oh [ __ ] you're right yeah yeah i think
people can underestimate how um
iterative video game writing actually is
i think uh some of the outside
perception from players is that it like
it just is what it was on day one and
they they don't have a vision of the
cuts and the things that got lost and
the pieces you had to pick up elsewhere
because things got lost it's definitely
never stops
more videos than anything because we are
yeah we we are still uh modifying as
until the last minute which you can't in
a movie i wish it were that simple um
that's what makes it so different like
go ahead i don't participate to that
anymore since a long time but um the
player-facing part because it's it's one
thing to have the story and i would say
that's what
maps to the in in the movies industry
that would be the dialogue or whatever
the script right but
uh the so the player facing is is also
super hard you have you know all the
things that you want the player to
understand
you uh
and and then you have like a different
set of of tools we have
you have the the of course the other
characters speaking to the player but
you also have visual uh storytelling
like let's make sure that
in order to convey the idea that in our
world we have you know whatever this
type of uh transmission device for
communication for example let's make
sure that some people mention it or that
there is like there are towers to
explain that and that is going to catch
the attention of the player and it makes
sense in our world and everything is
going what team does that come from like
when you're doing stuff like
environmental storytelling does that
tend to come from a writer or from a
narrative designer or does that also
come from art it's everybody yes
everybody all at once everybody feeds
everybody you know in a way uh sometimes
the the artists uh
will will they will hear that we have
this thing and they would think oh that
would be great to have like this nice
tower that and god right absolutely and
then once the tower is in then we think
we need to give it a name or and or like
to explain how and why and therefore
there's a book that talks about it
somewhere so it's really like a ping
pong between everybody i think that's
actually my favorite thing about working
in game dev in general is that it is so
collaborative and it's you know
potentially hundreds of people or
working towards a common goal for
several years after i started out in
journalism and that's so like you write
the thing and it's done and you do it in
a vacuum and then it just disappears two
hours after you publish it and it's gone
like working with a team on something of
people who constantly inspire you is
just the coolest thing in the world but
it can also be really challenging if
your communication's not good that's how
your studio falls apart like it it can
definitely be very tough to have those
things at once
you know i feel like the i feel like
putting story into the game or you know
communicating what certain things do
what is the story happening in this
environment you said like where does it
come from
i feel like oftentimes there's like
there's a spark of an idea
uh maybe in raff's example we have
something in our game called the
raleograph that's a way that people can
communicate with each other
it starts say for instance that it
started with a writer saying uh or a
narrative designer saying we need a
system where we can communicate with a
player across long distances because
that's just going to make our lives
easier design wise then you're like okay
cool and then from there it's like
uh the existence of that object in the
world the game the story of it
builds out across sort of all of the
disciplines in
across the studio and so it sort of like
fills up this story
tub with water it's a terrible analogy
but but the idea being that it's sort of
um it's more of like a
a building than it is like one person
had an idea and it struck lightning and
then it was done no it's sort of like
you know we're all building a house
together someone had an idea for
wouldn't it be cool if there was a house
there it's like okay great we need
everyone's help in order to what are the
rooms going to know what are they
looking for what are the roofs going to
be what is the foundation like a
programmer is like can you make sure
this thing has a solid foundation and
isn't going like this everywhere and how
are we going to decorate you know what
sort of shrubbery do we want on the
walkway because that's important too you
know it's like sort of all of it uh all
of it together and it seems like no one
person is responsible uh sort of all of
us at once
i strongly agree yeah it's absolutely
everybody and shout out to qa
oh my gosh yes i told me don't get me
loved qa on an immersive sim especially
i mean that's like one of the things how
did how does that even work i don't even
how do you qa
a game that's so
customizable
yeah you you can only to some level i
mean in our case we had to uh eventually
the big win was to
uh do uh
some sort of a close beta with a
thousand years
because i mean we have amazing qa and
they're very uh
seasoned in in in this in this uh they
can never play as much as players can
it's just not possible i mean after the
10 playthroughs you're gonna you're
gonna
somehow
do the same things that you've done you
you're not gonna think of those crazy
things so right even though it means you
know because of the job they're probably
better than any any of us but
it still you can't cover everything so
uh in our case the the the final win was
to do that and still we still have tons
of bugs so that we're fixing now by the
way
you know difference between a thousand
players and then when it goes to
hundreds of thousands of players yeah
so that's
yeah we own game pass so it's
we have like three hundred thousand
dollars really
wow good for us
that's great
well and one thing that i would say
about that too is um
in some ways that's
i mean it is a part of the narrative
design process the
because of the nature of our game which
again is immersive sim
you there are just an infinite number of
possible combinations of the way that
this the state of the game who which
characters did you kill which ones did
you not kill who did you turn in who
didn't you turn in
which quest object did you skip i mean
we let you visit any location you want
before you're supposed to did the player
do something there they went to the
final final boss first how does that
affect the story you can do that yep
give it a shot
oh man i mean wait to see i can't wait
to see speed runs of this game yes the
speed run on this game is going to be
like five minutes it's gonna be amazing
it was gonna be really good yeah yeah
but you know so
the
i feel like the narrative design process
for this
it's so iterative as it is for all games
but it's also like
you know we we consider
uh one or two versions of the main story
say the bounty hunter journey it's like
we imagine the player making one of
these two choices and these big pivotal
choice moments
but then there are all these little
choices that are happening all over the
place that we're trying to support too
and
you know as raf was saying sort of
trying to hold all of the possibilities
in your brain at once becomes kind of an
impossible exercise so a lot of it comes
from like you do a play test something
happens you didn't expect
you did a combination of things that was
strange and suddenly you arrive at a
moment where you think
all this crazy stuff happened and if the
game responded to me in this moment
right now in this way
what i just did would feel validated
by the designers and like
i was
making a concerted choice to do these
things and now the game is responding
validating my choices and i feel like i
have co-authored my playthrough because
there's this response from the game so
we would try to find all these and
julian was especially good at this our
our producer where he would say okay
well if you do this with shelby cross
and this thing and this other thing
what if we put a little bit of story
material out here on this like branch of
a branch yeah and then when the player
experiences that they think
holy [ __ ]
if they accounted for those like
three exponential branches and there was
something for me there
what else is here and so suddenly in
their mind it's like the game becomes
even more expansive than we have the
manpower to make yeah i mean it's the
game that validates you somehow right
yeah it sees me yeah
uh raph over your your time
working on these kinds of games i
imagine you've worked with a lot of
different writers uh what do you think
is the most important
quality in in when you're hiring a video
game ready to work on an immersive sim
like what are you looking for in that
hiring process
uh
so
outside of being smart like lucas we
can't all be like lucas i thought about
that uh
and so like
so that would be like this kind of
horizontal vert you know like this this
broad kind of thinking about like the
consequences and of everything you can
do in the world like when you that that
of course is extremely important i think
for any writer
but in the context of our type of games
i think with some of the hard ball uh
we we throw at them are things around
how do you
uh make a story without any cinematic
how do you
allow the players to
uh break your story
uh because those are those are very
uncomfortable for many for many writers
the the a lot of writers who would
imagine that they're gonna write the
story and then the somehow the the the
game is gonna shoehore since itself into
the into that story and uh we because
tons of games do that
uh which is not at all what we want yeah
so it does take like a bit of a dungeon
master kind of kind of mind i think
which which is more like a space of
possibility rather than
uh
yeah i guess you could try to hire a
writer who submits a brilliant story
but that wouldn't necessarily be
valuable to the kind of games that you
make totally yeah totally and most of it
the plot twist is interesting but it's
not really something that has tons and
tons of value to us as a as a
but we can uh i i i can write plot
twists i mean like in the the the the
one he's good at them too i will say
[Laughter]
oh yeah the ones you played before come
on yeah yeah that's in the first 10
minutes
so
those are not necessarily the things
that i'm looking uh into uh for
narrative designer or for a writer i'm
really looking who know how to create an
atmosphere
with independent elements uh people that
understand narrative uh visual
storytelling um
and possibilities because that's really
that thing it's like you place your
elements you know there's like this this
old shoe in the corner like a broken
like a burnt mattress and and a broken
chair and you just told the story that
is to me extremely interesting more than
someone who can write a story write a
story is not and also someone who can do
player facing uh yeah
because again like how do you do player
facing with very cheap tricks you know
some of it is that the narrative um the
visual but also uh having
simple and punchy dialogue
uh that are not interruptive or that are
not too heavy to read so it's
those are qualities that
you can't really guess in advance i mean
of course someone might have a resume
but even then in a team every there's so
many people so it's hard to know who
does what
uh i i try also to look at the past
games that people have written of course
there there's uh
i i value
people who understand dilemmas
moral dilemmas uh
ambiguity
i i love twisted characters that have
multiple uh dimensions uh
so
to name a few you know i was a huge fan
of fallout i was uh the original fallout
one and two and even later
uh i was uh uh yeah i mean that's all
moral dilemmas
yeah because it's so cool it's so cool
uh
wasteland is still like one of my
favorite series
ever yes all that family you know like
the obsidian uh black guy initially and
then they they became uh uh the the
people the arcanum and uh so like they
did the vampire bloodlines and and as
well then they became um
yeah so the company you're talking about
the wasteland they are it's brand
fargo's company you can remember the
name uh i can picture the logo let me
look it up
i don't want to not mention it but this
guy is like all of them you know
they really have this this uh this
culture and uh this it's really
something that is interesting to us as
reference for for some of the things
we're trying to do
i will say raf took a huge chance on me
you talked about looking at previous
games
i'd have [ __ ] for you to look at you
really took a chance and
you know i remember that though too
because like there are writers on my
team who don't have previous games
experience and
i'm of the impression um that there's
value in that because some people can be
limited by
thinking of other games too much like i
think that there's like a kind of
diversity on a writer's team is the kind
of stuff they consume and the kind of
things they've written before can all
funnel into this one thing where you get
a whole bunch of really really different
ideas
yeah definitely
for me it was in the case of lucas i
think now you know i might give too much
information but
about him now he's gonna be like oh
that's how you okay
yeah i'm interested to hear this yeah i
i want someone that is uh super smart
that
i can train in our style because you're
right like you get an uh someone that
comes like has too much of a big resume
and and they're gonna come with
so much baggage that is the wrong one
because they have all these habits about
like oh yeah
you know and you need someone that was
flexible cinematic here and a cinematic
there yeah yeah but at the same time
that would be
not a pushover you know someone yeah
you're like
okay so he's still gonna tell me
well ref i hear you but this thing
doesn't
what about this because like i fee you
know and sometimes it's hard because
younger designers if they work with me
they feel like okay i got to say yes you
know but uh but but i don't necessarily
want that i don't really i don't want
the opposite either i did i didn't want
someone would be like hard-headed and
say no to everything yeah that's not
real uh a way to you know to make
progress but uh so it's the right
balance someone that is going to voice
what what they think is important to
voice that really matters and at the
same time after two or three explanation
they would they will say okay that that
sounds uh you know unless they convince
me which you know which uh happens uh of
course
is that is that something you feel uh
lucas now we're heading uh uh no i love
this having like a post line
[Laughter]
it was funny because i just remember
raph asking me during my interviews like
what are your favorite games and i was
just like i was a huge nintendo fan
growing up i love zelda and mario and he
was just like
okay we're making weird west you know
we're making weird west right it's an
immersive sim and i was like what's that
i truly i had never heard the term
immersive sim before and i hadn't played
dishonored and pray at least you didn't
lie
i don't think i did it would be worse
right no i didn't i think i had watched
i think i had watched like an hour of
someone playing dishonored because i
knew i was about to get interviewed
i asked people have you played thief
have you played dishonored have you
played prey have you played fallout
uh have you played sex yeah i was like
nope and nope and nope and nope and nope
[Laughter]
again i still like ocarina of time okay
i'm not sure what this thief you speak
of is
exactly
no but i think like uh i
i was i was so grateful to to get the
job and uh it really was such a huge
learning experience for me and uh raph
and the rest of the team were super
patient with all of the sort of
you know
beginners errors that i that i was
making because i just i couldn't see
yet
what works and what doesn't without
trying it and see and learning through
bitter experience
hey doing the narrative design this way
for the story moment it just it's not
going to work it's going to create tons
of tons of labor for everyone and let's
just not do that now after going through
you know two years of working on weird
west i'm starting to be able to see
those things easier
um yeah we're not very patient uh but uh
so
it's just that
to an extent you missing a swing
mentality and you you managed to uh to
uh you know
i at least didn't drown
i just feel like it's valuable for
people to know that like that's a way
into video game writing it's like you
don't have to have already written video
games because that's the thing a lot of
people ask it's like i had done a little
bit of true contract freelance writing
and i hadn't done game jams but i had
obviously not worked on a triple a game
before going to work at santa monica
studio and i think a lot of people are
like well how do i start i'm this kind
of ride i'm like you can the option is
there with the enthusiasm but also you
obviously took the initiative by taking
courses and everything uh before i ask
another question wasteland originally
was into play and is now in exile and
exile yes
um and i really liked wasteland 3 as
well i thought it was great big fan of
wasteland what what all good games you
mentioned deus ex thief fallout are all
brilliant and dishonored and pray
obviously um
so to jump off of like those kinds of
games raph i'd love to ask
what do you what is your ideal for the
direction of video game storytelling
where do you where do you want to see it
head what do you see for the future ooh
juicy to the same question
i think um
i do like
i do like stories that acknowledge the
the pre the player's choices that's
something that is super important to me
and i think
uh i regret in some ways that technology
has been
focusing so much on the
on the visuals which yeah
part that doesn't really matter
uh we pretty we're already pretty
beautiful now you know we don't need to
go really like more hair more this more
that i think it's like just a waste of
time and like adding more offering more
cost to the production what i would love
to see
and i don't know if that will make sense
but it's the physics version
of storytelling i totally agree
so strongly agree
that we i i feel like we're in this
thing where there are a lot of great
games that have great storytelling
but we're not taking advantage of the
fact that this technology is effectively
limitless
in a way that like you said everything
is focusing on graphics and physics are
improving as well but where where's the
the storytelling version of that and i
don't think that like you're absolutely
right that i don't feel like it's
progressing a whole lot i think the more
games i see with no cinematics the more
impressed i am by that that's the
current thing that i find the most
jarring with anything that i play is
if there's a game
and i'm interested in the story and the
characters but i'm always bored from
gameplay even if gameplay is really cool
uh because i have to just sit and watch
a cutscene for five minutes i find that
so frustrating now that i like have
trouble playing games like that like
just i could be doing it i know you have
to figure out what
i could be doing gameplay else and
you know we don't want the half-life
locked in a room jumping around while
serious stories being told but like
that's where we started and it doesn't
feel like we've come as far as i would
have liked
since then yeah one of the issues i i'm
really curious about this too i mean
you're making me think of that uh ken
levine talk on narrative legos which
everyone talks about yeah which was
really really fascinating to watch i've
seen his game so curious really yeah i
want to talk about it so bad
i i just i hope it comes out it's like i
just i hope you can pull it off like
me too
we're all really curious to see what's
happening over there and i think
i agree with raph too i'm
i i think i have trouble envisioning
exactly what
those systems are because i keep coming
back to the bottleneck of
like
the stories players create using systems
are can be really awesome like the ones
that raf mentioned about you know you
bury your dead sun and then there's the
skull and you sell it for the whatever
or we had earlier in some of our testing
uh
what was it we have systems where
if you kill somebody and their family
member is present and they escape
they'll start a vendetta against you and
come back later and attack you
and there's also a random chance that
you're the the charac your player
characters parents will spawn in the
game so there was someone testing and
the mother and father had spawned in the
game and they killed
their father and then the mother ran
away and was like i'll get you for this
and then like later the mother came back
to like exact revenge
on the husband's death by killing the
player character which was her son so
you know like these super interesting
things that happen
but
but like and also
say again it's still mechanical right
it's like it's right it's not an author
it doesn't have the like emotion of an
authored story and i'm like can we ever
completely leave authored story
especially when
language itself if you're gonna do it
stories that are language based the
english language is just so hard to i
don't think i don't think you can remove
the the the writer uh good
[Laughter]
author
uh you need to set up a situation that
is uh relatable and interesting and uh
that is gonna
be compelling for the player to want to
fix
the problem what is the problem in this
game in this world and what i would wish
there was though in addition to all the
systems that we have which are kind of
like hinting towards what i would like
to see is like okay well if the player
wants to do it this way let him do it
this way or
but i think there could be and i don't
know how that's gonna happen but i wish
there was an a i wish i wish there was
an ai like a global ai that is there to
catch things that fall through the
cracks yeah in our game we have tons of
things that fall to the cracks and when
they pull to the cracks we have
you have a fallback you know and the
fallback can be a character going like
huh and then you go okay well it's not
quite play right but like we allow the
player to do it and it's gonna work but
i wish i wish the ai would be there to
know what to do in this kind of
situation okay we have this system with
that system with this bark
in that context we need to do that or if
not at least an ai that during
development would tell us
to tell us hey you know i found this
situation oh god that would be so
amazing and we could identify it seems
impossible just yeah very expensive
well i mean with machine learning and
all these things that are coming it it
seems like i mean i don't know if you've
seen disco diffusion it's pretty freaky
disco diffusion oh that's right oh my
god
it's it's from google it's uh you think
like that there's a mind behind this
like this you know it's it's like an ai
that's creating images it creates images
based on like text descriptions that you
get it's just it's just prompts
it's freaky it's always a little evil
and dark and uh and and it's bit but
it's like okay beautiful if this is
today i think in 10 years we will have
like some abs yeah some some of these
images could come from the mind of a
twisted artist uh and it's beautiful uh
so what's it called i'm gonna i'm gonna
make sure i check it out for ai to
assist us to uh to improve games somehow
but i don't know exactly how you think
that's the thing that fusion i think yes
i managed to get it yes now with turbo
apparently whatever that means um
v5 turbo it says um
you think that's something that somebody
like uh
like a unity would have to make or like
an epic would have to make or do you
think that that could come from a game
that want to solve that problem i don't
i don't want to be a generic tool that
just works for everybody yeah in theory
the what was it called um the nemesis
system was doing a bit of that like that
was a thing they were touching on but
just for this one particular uh
structure in uh was it shadow of war
shadow of mortal um
and that was the ai picking up on okay
well now this guy's dead so let's rank
up this guy or like he killed you so
let's rank him up but it obviously was
very very limited and i was actually
very surprised that uh
as many
that games weren't inspired by that that
we didn't see anybody use it afterwards
well we did uh
you know a lot of the a lot of the
things of course they that was the
feature of their game it was i mean the
game was good you know that was the
marketing right but the that part was
yes
it multiplied the fun of this of this
game and the the emotional engagement
like this hate that you have for yeah
that that that orc that comes back for a
third time and and and kicks your ass
again now he's got cool alma
[ __ ] that guy
yeah seriously
stronger a very very smart idea and uh
but yes it's it shows the power of uh
semi-procedural because of course it's
semi-offered too in in a way
uh but it's like customized per
playthrough per player yeah based on
what the player's done before and this
is extremely powerful emotionally and
i'm surprised that
not everybody jumped on that train i
mean we did with the vendetta system and
the front that is true we did with the
vendetta system it is but it does and we
don't have the breath to shine as much
as they do because they really invested
big and also like they have this super
close up on their faces i mean
that really works uh i believe x-com uh
did that too
the most recent x-com i haven't played
it
yeah there is a notion of a recurring
enemy
that is uh generated on the fly based on
chosen apparently
that's what the system is called is an x
company system called chosen that's cool
i didn't realize they did it that makes
me more interested in
playing it i always found xcom to be
just so like
to this conversation emotionally taxing
and i think probably part of it is that
i always name everybody in xcom after my
friends
and then i text my friends when they die
and i'm like you died
that i just get like messed up and very
very very difficult
exactly which is i guess what they're
going for
but yeah it does feel like something
that that when it came out i was like oh
everybody's gonna do this um and they
didn't and i know that part of that was
they've just i think
actually patented it i think wb pass
that last gm baby it's tricky because i
mean i
i hated that actually i tweeted about it
when it happened oh yeah it sucked yeah
i mean frankly it sucks for everyone
looks very well you can't do that i mean
this is game design like we all copy
each other to some degree we we we're
we all in iteration of a previous game
yeah and that's we need to stay this way
because otherwise everybody everybody's
going to start looking i mean what if
you pretend the polygon as i said game
over yeah
that was just an admissible and i think
like what they
eventually it was not receivable because
they i mean it is receivable in a very
very specific context
they had to frame it to to a level where
it's really okay nobody's really uh at
risk of doing that exact thing yeah
because otherwise it is very broad and
yeah i would hate to see the games
industry go down that road in general
because like you said like i mean to
your point lucas about playing ocarina
of time we're in this really interesting
era where like every devs that i
interview right now
so many directors
will tell you like ocarina of time is
one of their favorite games ever and i'm
very interested in what happens when we
get to the next generation where
nobody's played ocarina of time anymore
and that's like something else that
inspired everybody and like what that
wave turns into because to rap's point
we are all very iterative you're
everything is taking from everyone else
and there are a million reasons i wish
companies like nintendo were more candid
about the way that they make their games
so that people just had that information
more freely uh but it will be
interesting to see like a the next
generation of
what is fortnight you know like what are
they saying what are the kids are all
playing fortnight is like the
or is it all games of service i don't
know i hope not and it there's also an
interesting thing and
i
yeah would love to see a world where
where ken levine
what he envisioned in the the lego
building talk exists where it seems like
it's video games with less set pieces
less cutscenes
and environments that are more reactive
to the player and sure the story still
goes the same way and you still have the
same characters but they're just a
little bit more adaptive so you spend
five hours talking to this one npc they
might get more power the world starts to
look a little bit more the way that they
would prefer to i think dying light too
touched on that in a little bit with
some of the um environments you can
basically choose a faction to
align with and it'll change the way the
game world looks a little bit and i
think that's a that's a thing that i
feel like
we are slowly headed towards but it's
interesting because games like
like pub g
it's just a multiplayer map you spawn in
every time uh but
the other players online are the ones
that are creating the stories for you
and the conflict for you every time
uh yeah in a way that like i don't want
a world where we only have multiplayer
games and very pro single-player games
but there is also something to that
where the other
players are almost acting as your enemy
ai and creating these really unique
circumstances in
something like like pubg or h1z1 or dayz
was probably the biggest one where you'd
have people just like break your leg
and then leave just because they wanted
to and that's such a unique experience
and it's like i wonder if there's just
some world where we can make the ai do
exactly that with the same level of
unpredictability without breaking
everything
may i be like real spiteful [ __ ]
sometimes oh nice
you've got both options that would be
really nice too yeah i sort of wonder
like
to your
earlier point about um
well i'm just thinking i'm still
thinking about cut scenes and i'm still
thinking about the way we design games
and you know like raph and the people
uh in the sort of like immersive sim
cannon i've been thinking about this
stuff for a long time but
i'm wondering if the like linear
storytelling in games with lots of
cutscenes
which we can do so well now oh my gosh
like we can really knock those out of
the park the design is like it's on
point the scenes are amazingly active
yeah incredible actors beautiful right
incredible actors like
the set pieces are big and incredible
and all these things
i'm wondering if
i don't want those games to go away
i don't think they do no i don't think i
want them to i don't want them to either
but i'm wondering like what it looks
like when you start to mix a little
immersive sim in a game like that or or
if it's just like
i think that would happen i think
eventually the word immersive sim is
going to disappear because frankly uh to
i believe every game should have those
uh those values it's uh it's yeah that
they don't
uh any and you could probably have those
linear
uh movie style games where
you know you get a five minutes video
and then you kill people for 30 minutes
and then you have another five minutes
of video you could probably have some
uh
some elements of emotions in in that
format you know yeah i think to make
them more interesting to me at least
like
i i still i'm not sure that as much as
we can make cinematics that are
mind-blowing visually and like probably
a cool piece of storytelling at that
moment i'm still not sure that
from a from a narrative standpoint it's
a great format like because you're
you're gonna you're gonna do like this
super repetitive thing of killing uh
200 200 enemies for for 20 minutes and
then you're gonna have like five minutes
of cinematics that's that's more that's
what happens
uh how does it compare to a to a
two-hour movie or to a tv show that does
like really really compelling characters
over uh so yeah we all have examples of
like the rest of us or whatever they
were alright this one is amazing it's
that's true it's true like i i like yeah
again i don't want them to go away last
i work at santa monica studio god of war
has plenty of cutscenes and i think the
story in that game is incredible um
amazingly done i think so too but i i
also very strongly feel like
you're right that the future of the
industry to me feels like again video
games taking advantage of being video
games and not taking advantage of a
similar medium which is film
well the thing is like
you can
the thing that you can do in a game that
you can't do in any other storytelling
medium is you can
the participant can co-author the story
yeah like they are co-authors in a in a
video game you can do this in a novel
you can't do that the the the reader is
not writing it with you
the the movie watcher is not you know
there on set making the scenes with you
like in a game that is i feel like the
one thing that we have
that other mediums don't which is
you can because it is interactive the
player can co-author their experience
and it just is a fact that in a
cinematic the player isn't co-authoring
anything and it doesn't mean that
they're they don't belong at all but but
i think it just pays to
just note that and maybe just thinking
about like where is the dial is it like
or with a slider is it like cinematics
are at 10 and interactivity is at zero
or is it is it 50 50 or is it more over
here
um
yeah i imagine that that's like a
some creative directors have a very
tough job of trying to balance that of
like where they exist and where they
don't and
i can't imagine that's easy to figure
out like thankfully i don't have to do
that i just get told
this is here write it
yeah you have to totally do that part
that's that seems tough um but at this
point i'm just enthusiastic about
something i feel passionately about to
try to remember to be helpful to the
audience lucas uh number one piece of
advice for somebody who would like to
get into narrative design in video games
oh
um number one uh i think that the number
one thing is uh you have to be
a good writer you have to be able to
rely on good writing and so i feel like
a lot of times when i've spoken to
people who are interested in getting in
games and i ask what their writing
practices like they're like what writing
practice i just want to i've i just want
to write for games and i play games and
i like them and i want to write them i
feel like
it doesn't really matter what the medium
is honing your skills as a writer which
is something you can do in writing
writing workshops
uh you could form a writing group these
sorts of things like i think your
writing skills really need to
be on point and your storytelling skills
need to be on point first yeah and then
there's like like an actual good friend
the other day said to me
i think i might try to get into video
game writing because it seems like the
easiest way to get into game development
and did not understand why that was
there why that was so offensive i was
like that's their heart
okay yeah give it a shot it's harder
because there's there's no manual for
this either so like we're all sort of
cobbling together our
game writing education yeah everyone has
a different style too which thing that i
do think is very cool and probably like
makes it a
simple gateway is
that a lot of people come from a lot of
different backgrounds which is which is
awesome but i've also been writing books
since i was
six there you go there you go right a
bit different
the cool thing is like with game writing
at least like you know you've honed your
writing skill now there's make a twine
game they're like tools out there where
you can make a game on your own a
playable experience you can iterate you
can have people experience the game that
you've written i often encourage people
to just try do a game jam do anything to
get your writing in a playable form
so that you can see people play it
i think that's good advice uh ref how
about you what what is uh number one
piece of advice for
anybody looking to get into the
narrative side of the video game
industry
um
i mean it's a hard one i think uh
it's every every time it's a case by
case it's it's they
you know based on who they're gonna
approach it's the connecting with that
person from uh from uh
um
we need to i need to feel like because
it's it's gonna be a very
intimate work yeah we're going to work
very closely
um there might be some
uh emotions that come out sometimes
we're like frustration frustration or
whatever so we both need to feel very at
ease with uh
you know those those creative moments
creativity is it is some sort of
is an intimate thing yeah it's
kind of vulnerable
yeah
so
so i think uh it's going to be a case by
case that's an important thing where uh
you want to connect with whoever it is
that you're going to you're going to
work with and uh feel that person and
and make sure that you can
you can get dirty in in in like
uh and without feeling uncomfortable
about that because it's it's it you know
it will go funny you know you sometimes
you have to just like scrap an entire
thing and and you you gotta put put some
emotion on the side and
you know
but uh i would agree with lucas i mean a
lot of it is uh
so so in in that context then the the
game culture might in my case influence
a lot but funnily enough with lucas we
did not really have the same game
culture right so it's still like i felt
in this case i felt like the the
the capacity for the for the person to
be a good writer and also to really um
have that that intelligence that was
going to be very very helpful for a game
that is important
for our company also helpful for you
right like if you know that you don't
have to worry about that slipping
through the cracks and that that's his
job it makes your job a lot easier
yeah of course i'll tell you
someone that
i never have to repeat
more than once something is a huge win
yeah
any of the companies i've had uh i will
i will always give a lot a lot of uh
importance to that skill you asked
earlier what is a skill that is
important for you when you're looking
for a writer and it's good for for me
it's true for anything right if we talk
about something
i i don't want to have to put it in this
you know in a corner of my head and then
remind that person that thing yeah
very important to me that that person
remember the conversations we had
remember the thing we said we would do
etc because
you process so many things like as a
creative director you you can't you
can't you can't remem remind people
things
um
no i don't envy your position i can't
imagine it's easy i don't
let's just tell this how you take lots
of notes
take love like direct as creative
directors like i just feel like it just
seems so stressful like it just seems
like a lot of meetings and a lot of
stress
well i mean that's the other side you
know it's yeah you get the good and the
bad yeah which is true
can i give one more piece of advice this
is really important no one says this
uh
except susan o'connor says this
please
experience art outside of games yeah and
like live life outside of games because
the ideas that come
i i feel like some some folks who you
know like the main medium they've
consumed their whole life as games it
becomes a sort of like
uh
the cycle this sort of like you know
regurgitation and it's like i felt
myself in the museum
totally i felt myself doing the thing
that i had heard people make fun of game
devs fall when elden ring came out where
i went to everybody and i was like this
mechanic and you're like you can't just
walk in and then tell them about other
video games but um our director has said
that to me explicitly was like go watch
some movies this weekend seriously do
that watch the movies yeah and then go
for a walk in nature have some hobbies
like live life outside of games so that
you can bring experiences from the world
into the world
i always get my ideas for the next game
when i go on vacation uh
costa rica or whatever you know i'm like
there's nothing else after four days i'm
bored to my death and uh and then i
stopped and costa rica is how you came
up with weird west of course it makes
perfect sense
uh thank you both so much for joining me
to either of you have like twitter or
anything where anyone can find you
yeah we do uh
was it weird uh sorry
wolfie games
games
games again the creative director it's
very hard
and you said it's on game pass i've been
playing on steam um where else can
people check out weird west
uh playstation xbox and steam and
epic games and very soon google games as
well cool thank you both so much for
joining me
thank you thanks for having us has been
super fun yes it is it's just i get to
talk to people about things i like for
an hour it's like cheating
it doesn't feel like a podcast it's
great um thank you all for watching see
you next time
[Music]
mmm
[Music]
you